I just got an cool little minion that’s
gung-ho to try some experiments, so what do
you think would happen, if we let him play
with high voltage electricity? In this project
we’re repurposing a Neon Sign Transformer
to power some mad science experiments, and
push the boundaries on cooking with electricity.
Let’s start this experiment with a Neon
Sign Transformer. This one’s 12,000 volts,
and current limited to 30mA, which basically
means it’s less likely to kill you.
These kind of NSTs are getting outdated and
thrown away all the time, so if you make friends
with a contractor in the electric sign industry,
you might be able to get a whole load of them
just for buying him lunch. Ask me how I know
that.
Let’s connect a couple of alligator clips
to either side of the high voltage terminals,
then carefully connect the hot and neutral
leads to 120VAC. With the NST powered up,
you can actually feel the wires buzzing, and
if they get too close to each-other, the electricity
jumps from one lead to the other, forming
an electric bridge. This kind of electricity
is very aggressive, so make sure you don’t
get your hands too close to the leads themselves,
because you don’t want the electricity jumping
into you.
Now for our first experiment, I stopped by
a local toy store and got a little helper.
His name is Stuart, and we’ll start by strapping
10” nail spikes to his hands, secured in
place with black zip-ties. If we clip the
leads from the NST directly to the spikes
and turn on the power, our little minion gets
a fascinating look at electrified plasma,
up close and personal. Now you might have
noticed the tips of the nails glowing purple,
and the electricity seems to be really really
stretchy. That’s because once it jumps the
gap, the electrons ionize the air making it
more conductive, essentially forming a conduit
that lets power flow without wires. This is
one of the reasons that high voltage is so
dangerous. Because it can literally jump right
through the air and bite you, if you get too close.
Alright let’s try something a little safer.
I just built a Jacob’s ladder out of a 3/16”
steel rod, and a wooden base that I spray-painted
silver. The rods aren’t connected, but you
can see there’s a place for hooking a high
voltage lead to each individual rod. I bent
the wires so they they’re a quarter inch
apart at the bottom, then gradually spread
upward to 3-1/2” at the top. These magnetic
balls at the tips, are just to make it look cooler.
If we clip a lead to each of the rods, we
can safely plug in our NST, and turn on the
power from a distance. Now check out what’s
going on between the rods. There’s enough
voltage for the electricity to jump the air
gap at the bottom, then the arcs immediately
rocket upward, climbing toward the top.
This happens because when the electrons jump
the gap, they heat the air between the rods,
and as you know, hot air rises. The rising
air carries the electricity upward until it
gets stretched so wide it can’t hang on
anymore. So it gives up and goes back to jumping
the easier gap at the bottom. Which you can
see repeats over and over again indefinitely.
Alright, let’s try something a little bit
different. If we try holding the electrodes
horizontally, you can see the arc doesn’t
have anywhere to go, it just sits there peacefully.
But watch what happens if we blow on it with
a straw. The plasma quickly dissipates, and
you can see individual streams of electrons
jumping the gap, and a beautiful purple corona
spreading off to the sides. Which kind of looks like an electrical cotton candy.
Now for one last experiment, what do you think
would happen if we tried skewering two marshmallows
with the two electrodes? Look closely at the
gap when we turn on the power, and you’ll
see purple sparks jumping around, heating
the marshmallows from the inside out. Which
apparently makes it bubble and morph like
something right out of a sci-fi movie. A few
seconds later you can see mini smoke rings
shooting all around the room.
And just when we thought things couldn’t get any crazier the whole thing bursts into flames.
Well I guess that’s just what you’d expect when you hire a minion to do mad science experiments.
Well now you know how to repurpose old NSTs,
to build a 12,000 volt Jacob’s ladder, or
just to try roasting marshmallows, with science.
Well that’s it for now. If you liked this
project, perhaps you’ll like some of my
others. Check them out at www.thekingofrandom.com